do you think that there's because
i'm seeing it i'm hearing it i'm seeing
anecdotes
of people who are saying i've learned to
live with less
i don't know what i was thinking sure do
you think
that i think that's permanent do you
think that covet has the potential
to make saving great again
yes i think at least on the margin
i think i mean guess what 38 of families
with the hundred thousand dollars
of income didn't have a penny of savings
coming into this right and
when they were staring into into the
abyss
of no savings and potential job loss
with without perhaps a safety net from
the government and they made too much to
get stimulus checks
they must have been really having a hard
time
because that's a that must be a really
scary thing
and i think that could be a lasting
lesson
but i think i think there's more doses
of this lesson to come
i think that there's going to be a lot
of people
who are going to have to learn to live
with less they've already been
got the fear of god put into them that
they were staring into the abyss a few
months ago
but what about you need to say for a
rainy day and all of a sudden it's
raining what about the deflation that
would be caused by
a third of the labor force working from
home
i think i saw something that a third of
people want to work from home all the
time
yep well if they live in los angeles or
san francisco
why don't they just move to you know
some town in texas or something
and it's there's no taxes it's certainly
cheaper real estate
and obviously i'm going to pay that
person less
so that puts deflationary pressure on
all related
people in that whatever position that is
they're looking for for work and the
government seems
reticent to give money
to people that are more than double the
median household income
and those are people that probably could
lose their jobs or get downsized
to a lower wage simply because there
could be pressure
uh for those positions i i think that
well companies are in a cost cutting
mode right now they're gonna cost
there's no doubt about it and the
coveted thing has provided the work from
home experience
has provided i believe i know it has for
me insight
into sort of the performance
that is being delivered by individual
employees we've spoken about
that every company i know i i have
almost 300 employees we do our best
to be better than average but of course
not everybody can be better than average
by definition you know and and so
i think we've got less fat than most
places
but there's got to be a lot of
organizations that have a lot of fat in
it
and that that fat is being revealed it's
certainly just welsh when he ran ge used
to lay off something like 10 percent is
a policy
a policy of laying off 10 every year
just because you want to keep
people motivated you want to keep them
you know sort of a stick
you know give them a carrot on the bonus
and a stick on on the fear
[Music]
but it kind of shows you that he
believes that 10 is fat
yeah every year and so i think there's
insight that's being provided
and you know i think there's going to be
a lot less demand for commercial real
estate
oh gosh that's i mean if you think about
central business district cities in
america
that rely on public transportation and
how much
office property is in kind of the top 10
markets again that rely on public
transportation and there's just enormous
amounts
of and and this is this is the one asset
class nobody really talks about but it
is levered up to the hilt
yes it is yeah i mean the whole
commercial building thing
was just was it was in plain sight for
the last few years just staring you in
the face i mean
i just can't get over how many hotels
have been built
oh gosh i just can't get over it 50 of
them are full
service who's going to occupy these
hotels
[Music]
you